we welcome you back to CBS morning's
looking at a live shot of Buckingham
Palace you're going to see that a lot in
the next few weeks next few days for
sure we spent a lot of time looking back
at the legacy of Queen Elizabeth let's
take a moment to look ahead at King
Charles and his Reign well we know it
won't be nearly as long as his mother's
remember he's 73 years old she was 25
when she took the throne but he has
already started forging his own path you
could say this morning he told Britain's
Parliament he feels quote the weight of
History Mark Phillips is outside
Buckingham Palace with more on that part
of the story Mark good morning to you
everybody's wondering what kind of King
he's going to be and of course that
remains to be seen good to see you
good to see you well good morning we're
into day four of what historians may now
come to call the Carolinian era an
ancient Royal term for Reigns under
Kings named Charles and already there
are signs that it will be different from
the just past Elizabethan one
[Music]
changes so much stays the same that's
the point of a royal transition
those crests on the Bugler's tunics e2r
they say Elizabeth II Regina for queen
there's some work in store for the Royal
seamstresses and for the people who
print the money and for the people who
have to replace all those mailboxes
Royal branding is about to change
King Charles has already changed the way
he signs his name it's now Charles R for
Rex King
Charles actually has a history of
handwriting issues which leads to
another change he's famous for sending
scribbled notes to government ministers
black spider memos they were called
often telling those ministers what they
should be doing or not doing
and they were considered improper as
members of the royal family let alone
future kings are not supposed to
interfere in policy my life will of
course change Charles admitted on
becoming King that his days as an
advocate are over it will no longer be
possible for me to give so much of my
time and energies to the Charities at
issues for which I care so deeply he was
saying very clearly I put that behind me
he said on other occasions and he really
repeated it in the speech if in the past
he has been a contentious figure his AIM
now is to unify
but however much Charles holds his
tongue or his pen this will still be a
different kind of monarchy we never
really knew what the queen thought about
most things we all know what King
Charles thinks about a lot of things
these aren't
very different starting points
but what else will change did The Joint
appearance of the estranged princes
William and Harry and their wives Kate
and Megan mean another chapter of the
Royal Family Feud was about to close too
soon to tell we do know this Camilla the
queen consort is now officially part of
the Royal Furniture
and we know that the workings of the
monarchy are no mystery to Charles what
we don't know is exactly what he wants
to do with it does he want to make it
smaller as is often hinted with Harry
and Megan gone at least for now and with
prince Andrew sidelined it's shrinking
anyway one thing does seem clear the old
world pageantry of the House of Windsor
is part of the way Britain sees itself
and even if Charles turns out to be a
modernizing king he won't likely start
with that what about the world trappings
ceremonial uniforms with rows of medals
and swords and gold braid and what have
you could we stand a little less of that
I don't know I think in the age of the
Digital Universe we need every bit of
that we can get
there was a lot of talk about how hard
an act the queen would be to follow if
there's a consensus here it is that
Charles is doing all the right things
and that it's working Gail
all right as you said day four Mark
Phillips reporting from London we thank
you